[Aplausos]
[Música]
la película surcoreana parásitos acaba
de arrasar en los oscars por primera vez
en la historia una película en lengua no
inglesa se ha hecho con el premio
principal el oscar a la mejor película
además de otros tres galardones
así que si esto no fuera visual polític
podríamos pensar que el sur atraviesa
por un momento fantástico sin embargo ya
sabéis que aquí en visual político nos
gusta ir más allá y lo cierto es que la
economía surcoreana no atraviesa por sus
mejores momentos en un pasado vídeo aquí
os contamos como el modelo surcoreano
parece agotado hoy en este vídeo vamos a
hablar de otro de los grandes asuntos
que tienen en vilo a todos los
economistas del país
amigo escuela del sur y sobre todo seúl
y su área metropolitana tienen un
problema con su sector inmobiliario un
problema que se viene gestando desde
hace años hablamos de uno de los
mercados inmobiliarios más calientes más
frenéticos en estos momentos de todo el
planeta
y ojo porque no solo me estoy refiriendo
a las decenas y decenas cientos de grúas
que llevan años levantando nuevos
edificios por toda la ciudad estoy
hablando también de los precios
durante los últimos cinco años los
precios de la vivienda en seúl se han
disparado más de un 20 por ciento sobre
niveles que no eran precisamente bajos
todo lo contrario mientras tanto en el
mismo periodo la inflación acumulada se
ha situado en torno al 6%
es decir los precios de la vivienda ya
de por sí muy elevados han crecido muy
por encima del resto de precios y ahí
ahí es cuando empiezan los problemas
especialmente si hablamos de una
economía que parece exhausta
y no sólo eso tal y como podéis imaginar
esto ha hecho que las familias los
jóvenes sobre todo los jóvenes lo tengan
muy pero que muy complicado para iniciar
una vida independiente
[Música]
simplemente los precios están por las
nubes y las familias necesitan
endeudarse hasta las cejas para poder
acceder a una vivienda deuda de las
familias crece mucho más rápido que los
ingresos pues bien el caso es que ante
semejante panorama el actual presidente
münchen ha decidido hacer de este
problema una de sus prioridades
políticas
durante la campaña electoral que le
llevó al poder prometió tomar todas las
medidas que fueran necesarias para
desinflar los precios del sector
inmobiliario y conseguir que la vivienda
fuera asequible para los jóvenes
surcoreanos o suena de algo seguro que
si es toda una moda entre los políticos
de medio mundo
sin embargo amigos casi tres años
después de llegar al poder las cosas
están peor que nunca y eso que tal y
como veremos este presidente no se ha
andado con chiquitas
pero ahora bien cuáles son esas medidas
como ha querido mucho conseguir que la
vivienda sea asequible están funcionando
esas medidas que podemos aprender de
todos estos cambios cómo puede afectar
todo este asunto a la maltrecha economía
surcoreana pues bien atentos dar según
más inaccesible los datos son
demoledores breaks
no quiero bombardear os con cifras pero
hay unas pocas que resultan clave para
comprender la dimensión de este problema
por ejemplo hace cuatro años aún se les
comprar una vivienda le suponía 88 años
del salario medio íntegro cuando moon se
convirtió en presidente en mayo del 2017
la cifra ya había crecido hasta los 11
años y en estos momentos se estiman ya
en más de 14 años
por supuesto hablamos de viviendas
relativamente pequeñas y sin lujos de
esta forma un apartamento medio de unos
60 metros cuadrados en un barrio normal
puede costar casi medio millón de
dólares
[Música]
es decir el mercado inmobiliario de seúl
está prácticamente tan caliente como el
mismísimo mercado de londres el esfuerzo
para acceder hoy a una vivienda en esta
ciudad supera al de urbes como parís
singapur o nueva york
y eso eso no es todo a esta situación le
tenemos que añadir además la
desaceleración de la economía surcoreana
y el creciente deterioro en las cifras
de empleo por ejemplo el desempleo entre
los más jóvenes supera ya el 11 por
ciento un nivel anormalmente alto para
el país asiático el otrora dragón
asiático está dejando de rugir y es
precisamente aquí cuando saltan todas
las alarmas por un lado el acceso de los
más jóvenes a la vivienda se está
volviendo casi una misión imposible por
otro empiezan a crecer las dudas sobre
si los precios de las viviendas son o no
sostenibles entonces la pregunta que se
nos viene a la cabeza es si según no
está acaso frente a una burbuja a punto
de estallar
[Música]
sí creo que esa es una buena pregunta
amigos mucho y prometió acabar con los
problemas de la vivienda pero desde que
llegó al poder estos no han dejado de
crecer y crecer
ahora bien un momento la actual
situación del mercado inmobiliario no es
culpa de münchen sino que viene de muy
lejos ni más ni menos que de la época de
la presidenta conservadora para kun que
fue destituida por un enorme escándalo
de corrupción y ahora ahora duerme entre
rejas sí aunque parezca increíble esas
cosas pasan en algunos países pero qué
demonios hicieron los políticos
surcoreanos para que en algunas zonas de
según los precios de la vivienda hayan
crecido más rápido que en ciudades como
hong kong o montreal pues atentos el
origen del problema el de casi siempre
queridos amigos queridas amigas de
visual política el problema general de
la política es que nuestros
representantes suelen preocuparse más
del corto plazo de las próximas
elecciones que del medio y largo plazo
vamos que tienen muy pocos incentivos
para preocuparse de lo que vaya a
suceder más allá por eso es frecuente
que cuando meten las manos en
instituciones como por ejemplo puede ser
el banco central
la cosa no termine bien
muy bien eso es exactamente lo que ha
ocurrido en corea del sur la suma de
políticas monetarias expansivas para
favorecer la concesión de hipotecas
junto a las constantes regulaciones de
'quita y pon' en el sector inmobiliario
del país explican en buena medida todo
lo ocurrido
y ojo no lo digo yo nos lo cuenta la
anterior presidenta fijaos impulsaría
drásticamente el mercado inmobiliario y
relajar en las regulaciones innecesarias
para que la economía pueda revitalizar
se muchas medidas adoptadas para evitar
el recalentamiento del mercado
inmobiliario resultaron ser obstáculos
después de la caída del mercado éstas
deben aflojarse un poco expresidenta pac
y vaya si lo consiguió el mercado
inmobiliario en seúl va camino de
convertirse en el segundo más
inaccesible tan sólo por detrás de hong
kong
y ojo porque cuando la presidenta
hablaba de relajar regulaciones o se
refería a normas que limitarán la
construcción o encarecieran los
proyectos en absoluto se refería
fundamentalmente a adoptar la economía a
base de reducir los tipos de interés e
impulsar el crédito como si no hubiera
mañana
[Música]
como veis por ejemplo una reducción
enorme de los tipos de interés sin que
hubiera crisis alguna que la justificara
el objetivo esencial del gobierno fue
tal y como reconoce la propia
expresidenta alimentar a base de más y
más crédito el sector inmobiliario
de esa forma teóricamente se crearían
más empleos los precios y los salarios
subirían los surcoreanos verían su
patrimonio crecer y crecer los intereses
bajarían y los más jóvenes tendrían
todas las hipotecas que necesitarán para
comprar la casa que quisieran y así todo
el mundo contento no y no sólo eso aún
más los tipos bajos incentivan a los
ahorradores a invertir su dinero más
allá de los típicos depósitos de bancos
para obtener algo de rentabilidad
y donde invierten las familias su dinero
en periodos donde los precios de las
casas no paran de subir exacto en más
casas con lo que se alimenta aún más
todo este proceso más demanda
patrimonios más altos más promociones
inmobiliarias más empleos más salarios y
que viva las fiestas
todo suena bien verdad el problema
amigos es que es precisamente así como
se forman las burbujas especialmente las
burbujas inmobiliarias
llega un punto en el que los precios son
tan altos y las familias están tan
endeudadas que todo este proceso se para
y de repente revienta mientras tanto
hasta que llega este momento los últimos
años de toda esta carrera se hacen
especialmente duros para las personas
que quieren comprarse una casa los
precios son tan altos que han crecido de
tal forma que su distancia sobre los
salarios se vuelve sideral y el esfuerzo
para pagar las hipotecas casi titánicos
vacune sabía perfectamente lo que hacía
dopada la economía surcoreana para
cumplir su promesa cortoplacista que la
economía surcoreana que elegirá más de
un 3 por ciento al año el problema el
problema vendría después pero bueno eso
ya le tocaría a otro
y es exactamente aquí cuando llegamos a
una pregunta clave como creéis que se
puede solucionar todo este desaguisado y
eso eso es su difícil
echemos un vistazo al plan de münchen
para evitar que la burbuja estalle y al
mismo tiempo conseguir casas más
asequibles tendrá caso la fórmula mágica
atentos
contra un problema de intervención más
intervención
amigos frenar todo este proceso que
hemos visto una vez que coge velocidad
no resulta nada pero que nada fácil
puede que alguno de vosotros este
pensando bueno pues que suban los tipos
de interés y todo listo no pues no nos
resulta tan sencillo y desde luego no es
el mejor camino si eres un político que
quieres mantener altas tus cotas de
popularidad o estás pensando en la
reelección de tu partido
[Música]
la subida de tipos de interés o frenar
la concesión de créditos implicaría que
muchas personas no podrían pagar su
hipoteca y no sólo eso al encarecerse en
la financiación demanda de casas caería
eso haría que los precios cayeran y de
repente muchos promotores inmobiliarios
verían peligrar su propia existencia
y claro por supuesto todo esto no
afectaría solo exclusivamente a las
empresas inmobiliarias el mayor coste de
financiación y la menor demanda
conduciría a muchas empresas de todo
tipo a la bancarrota miles de empleos se
irían a la calle de repente los impagos
y la morosidad de los préstamos se
multiplicarían como setas el sistema
bancario comenzaría a temblar y suma y
sigue el desenlace todos lo conocemos
y lo más probable es que la burbuja nos
estallara en la mismísima cara una vez
que abres la caja de pandora cerrarla no
resulta tan sencillo jugar con el banco
central puede convertirse en la peor de
las pesadillas
ahora bien corea del sur ahora mismo no
está en esta situación y la pregunta que
podemos hacernos es que el día antes que
hacer un change pues bien su plan se
puso en marcha el día 13 de septiembre
del 2018
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ese día presentó un paquete de medidas
muy ambiciosas medidas que básicamente
consistieron en más regulación es decir
en tratar de frenar la espiral de
precios golpe de ley
[Música]
el gobierno de muna ha designado una
serie de zonas del país como zonas
especulativas un hombre con cierto sesgo
ideológico para denominar a las zonas
con alta demanda y con muchas
operaciones de compraventa de inmuebles
en esas zonas la mayoría en seúl se han
puesto en marcha restricciones
especiales las más importantes son la
prohibición de otorgar una hipoteca a
propietarios de varias viviendas la
restricción de las hipotecas a viviendas
de lujo cuyo fin no sea vivir en ellas y
el establecimiento de un límite del 40%
del precio de la vivienda a la
financiación que los bancos puedan
concederle a las empresas que compran
casas para posteriormente alquilar las
de esta forma lo que mucho persigue es
limitar el acceso al crédito a
determinados agentes como por ejemplo
los propietarios múltiples en otras
palabras quiere reducir artificialmente
la demanda para así frenar el incremento
de los precios además junto a estas
medidas el gobierno también anunció un
programa de viviendas públicas para
aumentar la oferta inmobiliaria a
precios tasados cerrados el gobierno
proporcionará 300.000 viviendas públicas
a partir de 2021 el gobierno completará
la compra de cuatro o cinco áreas
inactivas en seúl incheon y la provincia
de que un guilanea construir cuatro o
cinco nuevas ciudades residenciales
entre seúl y las grandes zonas
residenciales existentes de isan y
bundang y la pregunta que podemos
hacernos es tras estas duras medidas que
ocurrió logró muy sin estabilizar la
situación pues lo cierto es que sí pero
tan sólo durante un año los precios de
la vivienda remontan a pesar de las
duras regulaciones amigos si lo cierto
es que corea del sur se enfrenta a una
situación difícil
[Música]
por un lado su crecimiento económico se
ha ralentizado mucho por otro la burbuja
inmobiliaria no se ha frenado en cierto
modo porque el gobierno no sólo no ha
revertido la política monetaria
expansiva sino que la ha alimentado aún
más precisamente para hacer frente a la
desaceleración económica además las
políticas de münchen parecen estar
mermando la competitividad del país es
algo de lo que os hemos hablado ya en
este vídeo y amigos eso puede ser una
combinación explosiva
[Música]
y ojo porque no es la primera vez que
este país atraviesa una situación
similar ocurrió también durante finales
de los 80 y principios de los 90 algo
que por cierto terminó con la gran
crisis del 98 pero llegó a este punto
algunas de las preguntas que podemos
hacernos son como puede corea del sur-
escapar de esta situación es más
regulación la clave de lograrlo puede
estar corea del sur al borde de la
explosión de una gran burbuja auspiciada
por las constantes intervenciones
monetarias y las regulaciones de 'quita
y pon' son muchas las preguntas sí y
como siempre en visual política
estaremos muy atentos a lo que ocurra y
tú qué crees crees que está justificado
que los gobiernos intervengan el mercado
cada vez que consideren que los precios
han subido demasiado como siempre
nuestras son las preguntas pero cuestan
las respuestas dejadnos lo que pensáis
por aquí debajo en los comentarios ya
sabéis que os ha gustado este vídeo no
olvidéis darle al botón de like i
suscribiros al canal si aún no lo habéis
hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]